what is with fencing for batgirls oh you
might be the queen of mean Audrey but we
all know that evil never gets its way
heroes and love are just too powerful to
beat sure you stole maleficent scepter
and the queen's crown
but there was no way Mao and the rest of
the BK's were going to let you get away
with it it was only a matter of time
before you got defeated we only have one
single request for you Audrey can you
please keep your awesome new look that
bright pink hair is everything there's
no question that Audrey is the real
villain in descendants three but the
question we're left pondering is how
will she be defeated
keep watching to the end to discover the
unlikely alliance that could save Audrey
from her meanness and in turn save the
day when Disney released the new villain
reveal teaser on July 26 2019 it
confirmed what we all suspected for a
long time Audrey is the real baddie of
descendants three but we also know that
there's no way she'll be victorious the
queen of mean will get defeated the only
question is how we've got a few Furious
as to how Audrey could be taken down and
also how she could be saved and made
good again not to do the right thing in
the end first up is Hades ember we can't
help but think this magical blue crystal
is going to play a part in Audrey's
retribution after all in the official
trailer mal says the only thing more
powerful than the curse of the sceptre
is Hades Enver we know for sure that
Audrey stole Maleficent sector so the
key to defeating her is the Ember but
how perhaps it's something to do with
Hades himself it's hard to imagine who
would possibly want to harm him
in the mystery trailer we get a glimpse
of Haiti standing over Audrey while she
sleeps in bed he's holding the amber and
it looks like he's performing some sort
of spell over her the fact that Audrey's
grandma queen leah is sitting by letting
this happen makes us think that Hades is
curing rather than cursing at least
that's what queen leah might think but
could it really be a selfless act on
Hades part or something more sinister
note that audrey has light pink streaks
in the scene just like she has when Ben
proposes to mal when we see Audrey as
the queen of means she has dark pink
hair so it's likely this scene takes
place before Audrey goes full-on evil
could Hades have cut a deal with Queen
Leah to wake Audrey from the sleeping
spell
but Leah couldn't have realized was that
Audrey would head to the villain side
upon awaking but it's often the case
that the thing that harms you also heals
you perhaps in the end someone uses
Hades Ember again but this time remove
Audrey's meanness we're left wondering
who would do that could Hades turn good
to and save the day by saving Audrey
from her vengeful self or will it be now
after all Mao could have the embers
power inside her she says when Hades was
using the Ember on her
and what if Hades was actually replacing
the power Mao inherited from her mom
Maleficent with his power from the Ember
that could explain why mouths hair turns
from purple to blue in this third movie
there is another way that Audrey could
be made good again and it's got nothing
to do with spells or magic objects it's
to do with the friendship in the new
villain reveal teaser Audrey says the
price that she's willing to pay for
vengeance is expensive but she adds
there's nothing to lose when you're
lonely and friendless so perhaps if
Audrey can see her way out of feeling
that way she'll stop perpetrating evil
but who could show Audrey the true power
of friendship Jane is one possibility in
the official trailer we see Jane going
underwater
perhaps us how she escapes the sleeping
spell and that would mean she's
available to help Audrey come to her
senses one ak2 another but there's a VK
that could also play the part in the
first descendants movie mal uses the
power of friendship to defeat her mom at
Ben's coronation mal chance that
transformed Dragon Maleficent into a
lizard could mal help turn Audrey from
queen of mean to nice princess again
through the power of friendship we see
mal as a dragon in the d3 trailer but
given that she's breathing flames at a
figure that looks like Audrey perhaps
she's not reaching out the hand of
friendship and it's clear that Audrey's
evil acts are all about getting revenge
on now for being with been in the
villain revealed teaser Audrey talks
about teaching mal a lesson by becoming
a queen whose reign will be endless so
she's not going to become besties with
mal without a serious change of heart
but there's another VK who could sway
Audrey in the right direction in
Audrey's royal return we
here at the spa getting a makeover in
recounting the events of descendants -
she refers to Emma as possibly the only
girl in the world who hates mal more
than I do
so we know that Audrey and uma have one
major thing in common mal will fall
could Emma be the one to offer
Audrey friendship and if Emma somehow
manages to forgive Mao for her past
wrongs then perhaps she could convince
Audrey to do the same
it sounds like an unlikely alliance but
wouldn't it be amazing if that did
happen how do you think Audrey will be
defeated let us know in the comments
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]